[Music]
how do I feel when I put it on the Ramon
Z of back when the new people were
travelling in the bush and just
visualizing how they were before the
settlers came
it just gives me the reminder of who I
am and where I come from
[Music]
I get nervous when I go out there
because everyone's like eyes on me you
know I'm bringing the high energy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm born and raised in Thunder Bay I
come from the bear clan my reservation
is long like 58 First Nation the
Anishinabe a culture is very traditional
power techno or just techno in general
is it's quite new to this community so
many friends and family and the elders
they know me when I was a little boy you
know just running around and my grass
outfit at the powwow is here hey how's
it going good night
I'm from here 258 yeah yeah how does
they say 58 jump this is one of my beats
right here what do you think yeah yeah
people they look up to you yes yeah yeah
one talks about cheer they already know
like oh there's Joshua and now they're
starting to know Oh classic roots
[Music]
back in their late 90s I was a DJ and I
played just local bars nothing really
bigger spectacular but I remember Josh
saying that he never got into that kind
of music and he would never try to mix
songs together and he said no I'm gonna
do something else with my life gonna be
a doctor or a lawyer just a typical
teenage dreams and then almost 20 years
later all sudden he's DJing and part of
what's making them so popular nowadays
is the techno music and the dance music
and learning to blend it in a good way
[Music]
I'm ready to spit some flames
[Music]
yeah like how you did that it put there
yes those chords are just
[Music]
well you know the track is started it's
so great I'm really really happy that we
all collaborated I like how you know
Toronto and and our community to really
kind of taught me a lot it's making
yourself uncomfortable that that's what
you have to do like that's how you like
actually experience like growth moving
down here it's just like that's an
uncomfortable thing it took me like like
eight years to be able to like finally
just sit down and write a song that
sounds like me yeah if you want to
actually make it and like do something
like you have to have that struggle
otherwise what are you working for the
big challenge right now Berlin Germany
Berlin oh my that's where you need to be
like that's where the techno thing is
like biggest right in the world the
world surround them to Berlin and be
good hit it's gonna be good chapter
my family colors blue and it represents
healing
and the green red represents the
springtime
and the orange and red it represents the
sunset and the sunrise growing up I was
taught to respect the regalia you've got
to understand the history and learn to
heal yourself and love yourself with
that regalia
[Music]
for me tech note it's something I really
fell in love with it like I couldn't
resist to keep on dancing to that sound
I just asked for my heart and dance for
the passion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's very few producers out there
that are making good Paulo step or run
off of that and Josh has taken it in his
own direction always doing techno and
house
[Applause]
[Music]
to see his work ethic and just see home
energetic is towards his craft it pushes
me inspires me
[Music]
if I can make music if he can show off
what he's doing we can get image one
person out there to actually see the
beautiful culture that we are
[Applause]
[Applause]
as an indigenous person I feel that's
important it's showing that we're still
here we're here doing things better my
teen days I was just another guy who
dreamed so much but it can't go nowhere
without any leadership around I was
bullied a lot I think I was like 16 or
17 I was hanging around the wrong crowd
I blacked out and then I woke up in a
jail felt destroyed that next day and
that's when I just meant that decision
and do this anymore
[Music]
[Music]
with music I feel no pain it's going on
13 year now from being sober so I'm
really really happy that you know this
whole route of on the red road it you
know made me a better way of to
understand about life you know well that
was the biggest thing I always said you
could be anything you want to be yeah
and if you take care of your mind body
heart and spirit first and foremost if
you can be successful at anything you've
always come back home and you've always
stayed connected to your roots
yes and you're giving back to the young
people and that and that makes this
whole cycle complete it's so rare but
it's amazing for me to see just one
person who feels the same way as I do
towards music or dancing because you can
see that they're gonna try it again
eventually
what are these I'm gonna start playing
some music well I'll just listen I'm
gonna mix the tracks together it's gonna
be a journey
[Music]
[Music]
I'll get your truck
did you try here okay I'll tell you what
I'll tell you went five six seven eight
go
[Music]
you can also add your word price if
you're wanting for like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love music I love dancing
[Music]
but I'm changing
I'm going to Berlin because I really
want to create something new I'm gonna
start busking
I'm gonna use my regalia and educate the
people there about the native culture I
could see myself touring across Europe
dancing DJing producing when you ask for
things asking to creator or any God if
you really want them and you will go and
that's what I believe in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]